Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich möchte dich hiermit auffordern, das Pfälzerlied zu singen.
Schon wieder Katastrophenalarm.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 533 vom 21.
September 2025 und wir sind ganz beschwingt und singen ein Volkslied,
ein Volkslied aus der Zukunft.
Ja, so läuft das jetzt. Also ich fand ja früher schon, dass man eigentlich gewarnt
werden sollte, wenn so Volksliga-Sendungen in Fernsehen kommen.
Da gab es ja so einiges. Hatten wir nicht neulich irgendwie festgestellt,
dass du nicht weißt, wer Heinz Schenk ist?
Hatten wir festgestellt.
Ja, genau. Heinz Schenk hat ja nichts gesagt. Hat mich nicht gewundert,
weil das ist jetzt auch was für alte Leute jetzt sozusagen.
Und diese Leute, die nur alte Leute kennen, die waren früher ganz viel im Fernsehen,
da haben immer so Volkslied-Sendungen gemacht und da wäre es ganz gut gewesen,
wenn man vorher nochmal eine Warnung ausgesprochen hätte.
Mit diesem Heinz Schenk, da ging es doch darum, dass sie irgendwie,
dass es einen Preis nach dem geben sollte und den wollte keiner haben, ne?
Genau.
Das war das, ne?
Das ist der, ne? Das war der. Ja, das ist natürlich schade für Heinz Schenk, ne?
Irgendwie Ist halt ein Boomer Will keiner einen Preis Ja.
Also ich meine Nichts gegen Heinz Schenk Der hat sich Mühe gegeben War ja so
ein Hesse und der hat dann auch so Das Hessentum auch ins Fernsehen gebracht,
Ja, das ist wichtig fürs Fernsehen Genau Naja, auf jeden Fall,
in der Pfalz,
genauer in Bad Dürkheim, da läuft es anders.
Also da haben die sich gedacht so, ah, die haben doch hier irgendwie so eine
Warn-App alle installiert.
Weißt du, so wie ich, der ich dann in Schweden sitze und gewarnt werde? Katwarn.
Und dann kam irgendwie für 7000 Leute ist dann Katwarn losgegangen.
Und zur Erinnerung, Katwarn hat ja diese spezielle Warnstufe,
die nur manche Apps bekommen dürfen.
Womit sozusagen auch noch, wenn die stumm geschaltet sind, kommt es halt trotzdem noch durch.
Ja, was man den meisten Apps möglichst nicht geben will, weil man weiß,
die machen damit eh dann nur Werbung oder so einen Scheiß.
Genau. Genau. Aber der Katwan ist ja Serious Business.
Aber im Landkreis Bad Dürkheim haben dann Leute, die irgendwie die Möglichkeit
haben, solche Warnungen zu melden.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich das gedacht haben oder ob das eher ein Fehler war. Wollen wir mal so,
fair sein und sagen, das war ein Fehler. Aber da sie da ein lokales Volksfest
hatten, wollten sie dann irgendwie die Besucher dieses Volksfestes auffordern,
doch gemeinsam das Pfälzerlied zu singen.
Und das Pfälzer Lied, ja, diese Aufforderung, die haben sie dann irgendwie bei
Katwan in der Kategorie Warnung.
So, jetzt so, jetzt demnächst wird dein Haus weggespült, so auf dem Level.
Und dann haben die dann über Katwan, über das Themen-Abo Wurstmarkt hätte das
eigentlich laufen sollen.
Also wenn du das Themen-Abo Wurstmarkt abonniert hast, dann könntest du halt auch sowas bekommen.
Aber was war da jetzt? Also ich, also die haben einfach damit gescherzt,
ne? Also da war einfach einer und hatte so.
Ich hab das Browser-Fan da noch auf. Ja, du kannst halt irgendwie so Themenabos
offensichtlich abonnieren, so, und wenn du Wurstmarkt abonniert hättest,
dann hättest du eigentlich dann das auch bekommen sollen.
Aber das haben halt dann alle bekommen, die halt irgendwie Katwan hatten,
weil sie halt irgendwie da gerade in der Gegend waren.
Weil das war halt jetzt einfach mal das Wichtigste, was da gerade in Bad Dürkheim passiert ist.
War halt jetzt gerade kein Sturm, war halt kein Blitzeinschlag,
kein Hochwasser, nix, kein Waldbrand, sondern halt einfach ein Pelzerlied.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie das so ist in Bad Dürkheim,
Wenn man jetzt Pfälzer-Lied singt, das dann auch zu so einer Ausnahmesituation führt? Keine Ahnung.
Wenn man davor warnen muss. Sie haben doch einfach nur Scheiße mit dem Ding gebaut, oder? Ja.
Die haben Scheiße mit dem Ding gebaut. Okay.
Gut, und jetzt fliegt die App aus dem... Jetzt kann Kappa nicht mehr warnen,
weil Apple sagt, ne Leute, so nicht...
Naja, auf jeden Fall müssen sie sich mal ein bisschen darüber Gedanken machen,
wer denn jetzt so die Berechtigung hat, da bestimmte Dinge einzustellen.
In welcher Kategorie und so weiter.
Ich vermute mal, dass da noch eine Schwachstelle vorlag in dieser Meldekette.
Ja, also das klingt nach, entweder das Vier-Augen-Prinzip wurde nicht angewandt
oder das Vier-Augen-Prinzip hatte auch ein halt mal mein Bier-Prinzip.
Aber auf jeden Fall. Na gut, sehr schön. Kommen wir zum Feedback. Du kannst es vorlesen.
Erstaunlich wenig Feedback. Vielen Dank dafür.
Vorbereitung ging dann ein bisschen schneller. Nee, ist super.
Wir freuen uns ja immer, wenn was kommt, aber diesmal war es dann so sehr überschaubar.
Deswegen lese ich einfach mal zwei vor, die sich mehr oder weniger derselben
generellen Thematik widmen, nämlich unsere Diskussion über diese ganze Lizensierung von.
AI-Maschinen, die gerne an die Inhalte auf Webseiten möchten und so weiter.
Und ja, dazu äußert sich zunächst einmal MinMax.
Linus sagt, dass Perplexity gesagt habe, dass sie die Robots TXT ignorieren
und einfach so weitercrawlen.
Die Info kommt ursprünglich von Cloudflare, die dazu einen Blogpost geschrieben haben.
Was Perplexity, beziehungsweise der CEO von Perplexity, Aravind Srinavas sagt,
der von Cloudflare identifizierte Traffic wurde durch den Perplexity Comet Browser
verursacht und Cloudflare war zu dumm, das zu unterscheiden.
Also die KI-Firmen haben jetzt alle irgendwie auch noch ihre eigenen Browser,
wo sie ihren Kram einbauen.
Das Geschäftsmodell von Cloudflare ist es, Webseiten vor unerwünschtem Traffic zu schützen.
Das weiten sie nun auf unerwünschten KI-Traffic aus.
Cloudflare hat demnach ein Marketinginteresse, das Verhalten von Perplexity zu skandalieren.
Also wem möchte man glauben? Noch ein Nachtrag. Cloudflare hat ein System namens
Pay per Crawl in Private Beta.
Lizenzzahlungen an die Ersteller der Inhalte werden über Cloudflare abgewickelt.
Ein Bot, der nicht zahlt, bekommt ein 402 zurück.
Das System ist geeignet, um Lizenzvereinbarungen nach dem RSL-Standard technisch
durchzusetzen, was wir besprochen haben.
Ähnlich gelagert ist der Kommentar von MSP. Ergänzend zur KI-Content-Lizenz-Thematik
sollte erwähnt werden, dass verschiedene Bots der KI-Unternehmen mit unterschiedlichem
Ziel eine Webseite unterschiedlich oft besuchen.
Neben dem Training des LLM kommt noch der Crawler-Bot für den Suchindex hinzu
und letztlich auch der Bot, der während einer Anfrage gegebenenfalls die Webseite durchliest.
Heißt, wenn man Chat-GPT fragt, ob die neueste Folge von Logbuch-Netzpolitik
anhand des Transkripts zusammengefasst werden kann, dann ist dies mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit nicht im Trainingsset des Basismodells enthalten.
Was ein Skandal ist, wenn ich das mal so kurz anmerken darf.
Nachdessen wird im Hintergrund das Netz durchsucht, die Seite letztlich gelesen
und deren Inhalt genutzt.
So wie sich mir der Sachverhalt darstellt, ist das Crawling für das Training von neuen LLMs,
das vielleicht alle paar Wochen oder Monate passiert und eher dem generellen
Sprachvermögen der Modelle dient, weniger das Problem als vielmehr,
dass im Hintergrund nach einem Prompt etliche Seiten durchgelesen werden und
damit in viel höherer Frequenz für Traffic sorgen, der aber keine Werbeeinnahmen generiert.
Das gilt insbesondere für Perplexity, deren Geschäftsmodell die KI-basierte Websuche ist.
Andererseits ist es so auch viel leichter die Quelle zu benennen und gezielt zu bezahlen ja okay.
Danke für die Aufklärung, das hatte ich so nicht mehr präsent ich weiß,
dass ich das groß behandelt oder groß mich auseinander gesetzt hatte,
dass es den Vorwurf gab aber eben nicht,
diese Erklärung, die da jetzt gerade kommt, ist natürlich auch naheliegend und ja, dieser,
Comet oder Comet Browser oder wie auch immer man den aussprechen möchte,
ist ein ganz interessantes Ding von Perplexity, zeigt so ein bisschen,
wohin die Richtung geht.
Wir hatten das ja schon besprochen in der Sendung.
Wir wollen nur den Internetknopf kaufen, dass Perplexity ja auch Interesse hatte,
Chrome zu kaufen, um sich da diese Nutzerbasis quasi zu sichern. Vielen Dank.
Tja, ansonsten benehmen sich alle schlecht im Internet.
Ja, es ist, oh je.
Ein US-amerikanischer Influencer namens Charlie Kirk wurde bei einem öffentlichen Auftritt erschossen.
Aus der Ferne von jemandem, den man inzwischen gefasst hat.
Und, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, der, was jetzt auch nicht wundert,
nicht sonderlich verwundert, politische Motive hatte, insbesondere,
dass ihm das, was der Charlie Kirk gesagt hat, nicht gefallen hat.
Der Charlie Kirk, so viel kann man glaube ich sicher sagen, ist eher an dem,
schärferen rechten Rand des politischen Spektrums unterwegs und in den USA.
Hat dieser Mord jetzt die fürchterlichen Konsequenzen neben dem fürchterlichen
Tod eines Menschen und der Traumatisierung der Menschen, die diesen Mord vor
ihren Augen sehen mussten,
jetzt auch die politischen fürchterlichen Konsequenzen, die solche Geschehnisse
leider häufig nach sich ziehen, dass ja,
Es gab natürlich von einigen Leuten die Mahnung zur Besonnenheit,
dass man sich jetzt nicht in den Hass und Vorwürfe und Hexenjagd,
und was nicht alles hinabsteigt.
Aber das waren natürlich nur sehr wenige. Und auf die haben auch nur sehr wenige gehört.
Trump hat dann irgendwie gesagt, er will jetzt die Antifa als Terrororganisation verbieten.
Irgendwie im niederländischen Parlament haben direkt auf Antrag von Gerd Wilders
dann auch Leute das direkt gemacht.
Also die haben quasi so eine Entscheidung getroffen, in der jetzt die Regierung
aufgefordert wird, quasi die Antifa als Terrororganisation.
Also eine völlig, völlig irrsinnige Überreaktion.
Moment, wenn die Antifa verboten wird, kriegen wir dann unser Demogeld nicht mehr?
Das wird auf jeden Fall schwieriger werden.
Und es gab dann auch einige Interviews, die ich gesehen habe,
die in den sozialen Medien, wo Leute quasi gefragt wurden, wie sie jetzt die
Ermordung von diesem Influencer da bewerten.
Und da haben sich einige zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass sie sich Schlimmeres vorstellen
könnten. ja, so sinngemäß oder noch blöder und unsinniger darauf reagiert.
Es gibt bestimmte Äußerungen, die sind einfach,
geschmacklos und ja, auch tatsächlich nicht zielführend, wenn man überlegt,
dass da eine ganze Menge Leute gerade verletzt sind und dass man natürlich damit
deren Hass weiter aufstachelt.
Verbindet sich sowas einfach.
Dann...
Wurde Jimmy Kimmel abgesetzt, so ein Late-Night-Talker, den kenne ich wiederum, der tatsächlich.
Also, und das ist ja das Bescheuerte daran, Jimmy Kimmel hatte,
hat nichts besonders Schlimmes zu diesem zu diesem Mord gesagt,
ganz im Gegenteil, er hatte,
wenn man sich irgendwie anschaut, was er so dazu verlautbart hat,
War er nämlich genau einer von denjenigen, die gesagt haben,
wir verfallen jetzt hier nicht in Hass und wir reißen uns jetzt zusammen.
Und in der darauffolgenden Sendung
hat er die Trump-Anhänger dafür kritisiert, dass sie das nicht tun.
Das war die inhaltliche Beschwerde, die man an seiner Sendung hatte.
Und der wurde dann ruckizucki abgesetzt. Die Sendung wird jetzt erstmal nicht mehr ausgestrahlt.
Schon sehr erstaunlich, weil der, also man kann eines sagen,
also in den USA gibt es ja nicht nur Meinungsfreiheit, sondern Redefreiheit.
Was ja nochmal ein bisschen höher hängt. Ja, also was quasi,
nicht nur darfst du eine Meinung haben, wie du willst, sondern du darfst auch sagen, was du willst.
Und ich würde sagen, der Charlie Kirk hat davon sehr viel Gebrauch gemacht.
Und das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Das war so sein Modell und der wurde auch tatsächlich von den liberalen Intellektuellen
des Landes dafür anerkannt.
Der Ezra Klein zum Beispiel sagt so sinngemäß, es gibt im Prinzip nichts,
was er gesagt hat, was ich richtig oder gut finde, aber das,
was er getan hat, wie er Politik betrieben hat, das war richtig.
Der hat dialogisiert, seine Show war im Prinzip,
also der ist insbesondere auf Universitäten
gegangen und hat dort Leute eingeladen, mit ihm zu diskutieren.
Natürlich hat er die alle in ein offenes Messer rennen lassen und rhetorisch
irgendwie platt gemacht, klar, sonst funktioniert das ja auch nicht.
Sonst wird daraus nicht ein Millionengeschäft aber,
ja, was der getan hat, war im Kontext der Redefreiheit,
und dass er eben seine politischen Ansichten selbstverständlich äußern kann,
und äußern können muss, ohne dass er irgendwie Angst haben muss dass jemand auf ihn schießt,
war das richtig und in Ordnung, was der getan hat.
Ja, Jimmy Kimmel hat kritisiert, dass seine Ermordung jetzt halt politisch ausgeschlachtet wird.
Damit ist er weg. Er ist damit der zweite Late-Night-Talker, der abgesetzt wird.
Für Stephen Colbert wurde das, auch das haben wir, glaube ich,
hier behandelt, dass das Stephen Colbert Report, dass es abgesetzt wird, jetzt zeitnah.
Nicht Colbert Report, weil ja das alte. Late Show heißt sie ja.
Late Night Report. Stephen Colbert heißt das, genau, nach ihm.
Und richtig behandelt haben wir es nicht, glaube ich, wir haben es erwähnt.
Wobei der Unterschied ist, dass Stephen Coobert quasi nicht verlängert wurde,
also die Sendung läuft noch und er ist on air,
aber das wird dann irgendwann nächstes Jahr enden und bei Jimmy Kimmel haben
sie ihn sozusagen sofort auf air genommen, was völlig absurd ist.
Völlig absurd und aber die FCC,
das müsste Federal Communications Commission sein, die
eben auch für die Regulation von Fernsehsendungen und die wahrscheinlich auch
zu der Beurteilung von Merchern und Kartellrecht in diesem Bereich,
beauftragt ist, die ist halt in der Hand der,
Regierung. Und die haben ja auch schon relativ klar durchblicken lassen,
wie sie denn mit so Sendern umgehen, wo Sachen gesagt werden,
die ihnen nicht gefallen.
Und Disney, denen das am Ende alles gehört,
bei denen stehen halt ein paar Merger an und die haben halt keinen Bock,
dass ihnen das Geschäftsmodell irgendwie durch abhanden kommt.
Also der Sender ist ABC. ABC gehört Aber zum Disney-Konzern,
was derzeit so in einer kleinen Boykottwelle mündet, ob die ausreichend Druck
ausbaut, daran darf man Zweifel haben.
Also auf jeden Fall würde ich, hätte ich eine Geschäftsbeziehung mit diesem
Unternehmen, würde ich die jetzt auch beenden.
Weil das ist also ja, sorry ich meine, da ist halt eine Regierung die auch,
und die machen ja auch überhaupt gar keinen Hehl daraus also,
nachdem der Colbert Vertrag nicht verlängert wurde hat Trump gesagt,
ja ich glaube Kimmel ist der nächste,
und das ist halt ein paar Monate her oder ein paar Wochen nur und zack,
wird der abgesägt das ist Also das ist, ja,
erstaunlich, erstaunlich viel Redefreiheit, die der, zumindest der gute Charlie Kirk hatte.
Jetzt haben irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, das ist ja auch so absurd,
wenn das richtig in mir vorbeigescrollt ist, hat hier die Beatrix von Storch,
hat dann irgendwie vorgeschlagen, der soll jetzt heilig gesprochen werden.
Als wenn die den gekannt hätte. Vielleicht kannte die den auch.
Wahrscheinlich kennt die den.
Wenn du hier auf dieses Portal mit dem irrefreundenden Namen News gehst,
diese neue Hetz-Seite von Nios.
Wie heißt der dabei? Der selbst für den Springer-Verlag irgendwann nicht mehr zu tragen war.
Reichelt, Julian Reichelt. Der hat sich da so eine neue Jauchegrube im Internet
gemacht und die machen da jetzt irgendwie Livestream von der Trauerfeier.
Also können die ja alles machen, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass das auch die Rechtsextremen hier in Deutschland nicht wussten, wer das ist.
Nee, das wird jetzt alles total hochgepeitscht und er wird dann heilig gesprochen sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Weil er halt jetzt irgendwie gestorben ist. Vorher war das halt nur so,
je t'nother Wasserträger dieser ganzen rechten Bewegung zugegebenermaßen relativ
erfolgreich da mit seinem Medien-Sachen.
Aber das sind halt auch andere und er war jetzt nicht in irgendeiner Form jetzt
ein besonderer Vordenker oder sonst irgendwas, sondern er ist halt jetzt ermordet
worden durch diesen anderen Wirrkopf,
der ja selber aus einer Magerfamilie stammt, weil es selber vielleicht nicht unbedingt,
weiß man nicht,
selber ein Magerverfechter war, aber definitiv jemand, der einfach schwer Schaden
genommen zu haben scheint aus diesen Umständen und ja, beschlossen hat,
jetzt irgendwie diesen Typen umzubringen.
Und das ist eigentlich auch ein Zeichen dafür, wie durcheinander mittlerweile.
Die Leute in den USA auch sind.
Das gepaart noch mit diesen ganzen frei verfügbaren Waffen führt halt jetzt
einfach auch zu Gewalt und jeder nutzt natürlich solche Events zu seinem eigenen Vorteil.
In diesem Fall sind natürlich dann halt Trump und Konsorten schnell dabei,
hier einen neuen Märtyrer auszurufen und jetzt mal ganz nebenbei noch alles
weg zu achsen, was halt auch nur wagt, sich dazu zu äußern mit dem Vorwurf,
das wäre jetzt alles inappropriate.
Also Free Speech, da sind sie halt immer schnell dabei, die zu fordern.
Da sind sie schnell dabei.
Wenn es um die eigene Speech geht, aber wenn andere Leute halt irgendwie mal
den Maul aufmachen, dann ist das halt irgendwie alles falsch.
Und das ist sehr bedenklich.
Dann kommentiert Dunja Hayali, sagt folgenden Satz.
Es ist nicht zu rechtfertigen, dass manche Gruppen seinen Tod feiern.
Auch nicht mit seinen oftmals abscheulichen, rassistischen, sexistischen und
menschenfeindlichen Aussagen.
Sie sagt ja, das ist nicht zu rechtfertigen, auch nicht damit.
Was ich denke, was ein Satz ist, der vollkommen korrekt ist.
Ja, weil, dass er, sag ich mal so, dass die Äußerungen von dem rassistisch und
sexistisch waren, das ist, glaube ich, jetzt nicht besonders strittig.
Und selbst wenn es nicht so wäre, ist das einfach erstmal eine Meinung, die man haben kann.
Das wäre jetzt nur Meinungsfreiheit, könnte man da fast sagen.
Also das ist einfach mal ein Satz, der völlig in Ordnung ist.
Weil sie ja eben sagt, es ist damit nicht zu rechtfertigen.
Dann wird aber ein Shitstorm losgetreten und ich würde denken,
dieses Newsportal war daran nicht unbeteiligt.
Aber zumindest wenn man die Seite anschaut, die beschäftigen sich seit längerer
Zeit, sagen wir mal, kritisch mit ihr als Person.
Jetzt wird sie also dann im Internet verbal attackiert, in zahlreichen Posts
mit dem Tod bedroht und hat dann jetzt angekündigt, sich für einige Tage aus
den sozialen Netzwerken zurückzuziehen.
Ähnlich erging es Elmar Thewesen, der in der Sendung Markus Lanz gesagt hat,
also der hat bei Markus Lanz gesagt, Kirk habe gesagt, dass Homosexuelle gesteinigt werden müssten.
Dann hat der Lanz nachgefragt und dann hat Theweson gesagt, ja damit hat er
sich auf die Bibel bezogen ja,
und dann ist das natürlich in Ordnung ja,
also wenn es in der Bibel steht dass Homosexuelle gesteinigt werden müssen,
dann ist das ja auch ein Grund den Charlie Kirk jetzt dafür heilig zu sprechen,
dass er die Bibel zitiert hat so, der hat also unglücklich zitiert keine Ahnung,
ich habe das auch nicht gesehen ja,
Aber er muss auf jeden Fall verlautbaren, dass er an dieser Stelle nicht ausführlich
genug war und nicht gesagt hat,
der bezieht sich auf religiös verblendete Hetzschriften namens Bibel. Ja.
Und dann hatte der ehemalige US-Botschafter Richard Grinnell,
hat dann gefordert, man solle dem das US-Visum entziehen,
weil er wäre linksradikal und würde immer wieder zu Gewalt gegen Menschen aufrufen,
mit denen er politisch nicht übereinstimme.
Also er...
What the fuck, ey. Was ist, also, dann können wir mal irgendwie wenigstens bei,
also kann man sich wirklich,
ich kann das ja verstehen, dass das irgendwie verletzend ist und dass so ein
politischer Mord auf jeden Fall die Nerven irgendwie blank liegen lässt.
Aber genau deswegen wählt man sich ja eben Vertreterinnen,
die in so einer Situation zur Einigkeit aufrufen und aufpassen,
dass solche Morde nicht die Wirkung in dem Zusammenhang der Gesellschaft entfalten,
die die teilweise Terroristen mit so etwas beabsichtigen.
In diesem Fall übrigens, ich habe das nur ein bisschen verfolgt,
derjenige, der den erschossen hat, hat sich in seinem Geständnis gegenüber seiner
Mitbewohnerin, ich weiß es nicht genau,
war halt englisch, konnte ich nicht sagen, ob das jetzt von einer weiblichen
oder mänlichen Person ist,
quasi gesagt, dass es halt dieser Hass ein Ende haben muss. Also gut,
das ist glaube ich relativ klar, dass du mit einem politischen Mord nicht den
Hass in den Griff kriegst. Also völlig beknackt.
Ja, aber du hast halt, wenn du eine Regierung hast, die dann,
also da kannst du dich, wenn du eine Regierung hast, die dann auch den Hass halt schürt.
Junge, Junge. Also dann kann man sich echt warm anziehen.
Ja, also man merkt auf jeden Fall, dass Trump und dieses ganze rechte Movement
in den USA einfach gerade maximal versucht durchzudrücken, was durchzudrücken ist,
um irgendwie alle in irgendeiner Form zu bestrafen, die ja jemals auch nur das
Wort gegen den König Trump erhoben haben.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich USA am Scheideweg und Europa insofern auch,
als dass wir halt hier auch Kräfte haben, die dieses Playbook gerne kopieren.
Ja, also News ist schon gefallen, kann man da glaube ich auf jeden Fall klar
in diese Reihe stellen, was so Scheinmedien betrifft, als eben auch Scheinparteien wie die AfD.
Und ja, das ist insofern auch überhaupt nichts Neues.
Neu ist jetzt einfach nur die Intensität und Dreistigkeit, mit der das auch durchgespielt wird.
Und wie jetzt auch wirklich Druck auf die Institutionen gelegt wird.
Und man merkt auch, dass einfach viel der sogenannten Wehrhaftigkeit der Demokratie,
das liest sich immer ganz gut on paper.
Aber so wehrhaft ist die halt nicht unbedingt.
Also da muss man sich schon mal mehr Gedanken darüber machen,
wie man eine solche Wehrhaftigkeit mehr sicherstellen kann, als das jetzt derzeit der Fall ist.
Und das muss ich auch insbesondere in die USA fragen lassen,
also da fragen sich sicherlich auch einige schon, nur jetzt ist es halt gerade
zu spät, also derzeit ist nicht die Zeit um irgendwelche Schutzmechanismen neu
zu etablieren und einzubauen, sondern jetzt muss ich zeigen,
wie sehr ein System, was dann doch sehr viel auf Konventionen und Konsens basierte und basiert,
in dem Moment einfach komplett die Treppe runtergeworfen wird,
wo jemand einfach drauf scheißt auf den Konsens und auf die Konventionen und
in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch, was so die Gewaltteilung betrifft.
Weil FCC, haben wir schon genannt, diese ganzen angeblicher unabhängigen Institutionen,
innerhalb des Regierungsapparats, also die nicht wirklich weisungsgebunden sind
in dem Sinne, sollen ja unabhängig agieren, aber diese Unabhängigkeit ist dahin,
und genauso ist es halt auch jetzt mit den Medien.
Man hat in den USA ohnehin eine extrem.
Polarisierte Medienlandschaft, da ist es vollkommen normal, dass ein Fernsehsender
eben für irgendeinen bestimmten politischen Trend und in den meisten Fällen
halt einfach schlicht die Demokraten oder die Republikaner oder rechts oder links steht.
Es gibt nur noch wenige Sender, die so zumindest den Anschein haben,
so irgendwo in der Mitte zu stehen, so wie CBS und eben eigentlich auch ABC.
Während du halt dann mit Fox News, da ist natürlich eh alles vorbei und dann
gibt es noch ein paar beklopptere, noch viel rechtslastigere Sender,
wo man wirklich nur noch die Krise kriegt, wenn man da auch nur fünf Minuten zuschaut.
Oder auf der anderen Seite hast du in diesem liberalen Spektrum natürlich dann
sowas wie MSNBC, was halt irgendwie quasi alle unterbringt, die irgendwie die
noch nicht komplett den Verstand verloren haben.
Aber natürlich haben die auch dann wiederum so einen Bias,
dass sie jetzt nicht wirklich von einer Mitte als Medium akzeptiert wird,
was hier in irgendeiner Form auch als ausgleichender Faktor wahrgenommen werden kann.
Und das ist ein Dilemma, das hat sich über Jahre abgezeichnet.
Da leben wir jetzt drin und das sieht gerade gar nicht gut aus.
Also das ist sehr beunruhigend, was da passiert und da möchte ich,
da habe ich gerade noch nicht mal das richtige Maß an Optimismus am Start.
Es ist halt, also was, und jetzt kommen natürlich die klassischen,
also jetzt hast du den klassischen Quatsch, ne?
Jetzt kommen die ganzen, diese Cancel-Quatsch-Debatten wieder.
Wer wurde jetzt hier gecancelt, ne? Und hin und her.
Dann natürlich darf es nicht fehlen, bis irgendjemand wieder sagt,
dass die Anonymität im Internet muss weg, weil Dunja Hayali beschimpft wurde, ja?
Und das ist so, es ist so unwürdig, es ist so,
Es ist traurig, dass man diese Debatten nicht mehr einfach mal,
also dass wir nicht mehr miteinander reden können.
Es werden immer nur noch Menschen verteufelt und hier wird jetzt jemand gecancelt.
Ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer Julia Ruß ist,
aber die hat eine Sendung moderiert im NDR,
die den Namen klar hat und offenbar haben sich eine Reihe NDR-Mitarbeiter über
handwerkliche Mängel in dieser Sendung beschwert.
Und in Konsequenz ist jetzt, also das Ergebnis ist, dass sie diese Sendung jetzt
nicht mehr beim NDR macht, sondern beim BR und dort im Wechsel mit anderen KollegInnen.
Also das heißt, da hat es eine personelle Änderung gegeben, aber die macht weiterhin diese Sendung.
Also, ja.
Also worüber hat die jetzt berichtet?
Ich glaube, es war eine Politik-Sendung. Wie gesagt, ich kenne diese Sendung nicht.
Aber dem, was ich entnehme, ist es eine junge Konservative.
Und jetzt wurde irgendwas geändert und irgendwelche Leute waren mit,
also das, was ich lese, ich möchte da jetzt nichts, weil ich habe keine einzige
dieser Sendungen gesehen.
Ich stelle nur fest, da wird irgendeine Redakteurin, irgendeine Moderatorin
geht jetzt zu einem anderen öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender und kann da weiter ihre Sendungen machen.
Ich verstehe nicht genau, was jetzt das Geschrei ist.
Also, weißt du, wenn die jetzt abgesicht worden wäre oder so, keine Ahnung.
Oder wenn da irgendwie die Regierung die weggepresst hätte oder so.
Aber das ist halt, also, es geht immer nur noch um Menschen,
es geht immer nur noch um Hass und, hey, keine Ahnung. Also, es ist wirklich...
Sehr, sehr traurig anzusehen. Wie das überall verloren geht,
dass Menschen irgendwie mal
so bei der Sache bleiben und überhaupt noch irgendwie, naja, Lust haben,
sich mit Inhalten auseinanderzusetzen. Weißt du?
Also sozusagen, okay, hier gibt es ein Problem.
Für das Problem müssen wir jetzt eine Lösung finden. Meine Lösung ist,
keine Ahnung, diese. Deine Lösung ist diese.
Und rucki zucki hast du irgendwie zwei Leute, die sich nur noch als Nazi oder
Linksfaschist beschimpfen und nirgendwo in der Nähe sind, sich in irgendeine
inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung zu führen.
Und es mag auch sein, dass die niemals zueinander kommen werden inhaltlich.
Aber es wäre schön, wenn sie sich wenigstens inhaltlich auseinandersetzen würden
und nicht die ganze Zeit nur noch gegen irgendwelche,
Leute gehetzt wird oder irgendwelche weißt du, so bluttriefende Vorwürfe mit
Schaum vom Mund vorgetragen werden. Das ist wirklich,
ja, belastend.
Ja, das ist irgendwie eh unklar. Ich meine, jetzt geht die zum BR,
macht da klar, aber klar gibt es auch noch beim NDR und wenn sie jetzt irgendwie
stattdessen reingeholt haben, ist eine Ex-Bild-Chefin.
Ja, also ich ja, Ich verstehe es nicht, aber es zeigt, dass.
Und ich nehme das nur als Beispiel dafür, dass wir halt, weißt du, du führst.
Du führst diese Gespräche nicht mehr. Du führst keine inhaltlichen Gespräche.
Da steht auch nicht, also offenbar haben ja, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
nochmal Vorsicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer Julia Ruß ist, aber offenbar haben
sich da mehrere Leute beim NDR irgendwie einen Brief geschrieben,
in dem sie sagen, dass sie halt
journalistische Mängel in einer Sendung hatte. Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann das auch nicht beurteilen. Ich würde aber sehr gerne,
viel lieber, die Diskussion über die journalistischen Mängel führen.
Weil das ist eine, wo man nicht über Glauben oder Identität oder ihr seid jetzt
die linke Antifa oder ihr seid die Terror-Antifa und ihr seid die Nazis,
wo man noch irgendwo halbwegs eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung hat.
Finde ich aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Hat auch offenbar niemand ein Interesse dran.
Dass das noch wirklich diskutiert wird oder aufgearbeitet wird oder was auch immer.
Ich weiß zum Beispiel, konnte ich jetzt nicht finden, ob da irgendjemand beim
NDR geschrieben hat, ja hier in der Sendung war was falsch oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Und das ist, also das ist, wenn wir das verlieren, also was soll das noch?
Weißt du, es wird nicht mehr rational miteinander geredet, es wird nur noch irgendwie rumge.
Rumgekeift. also ich kann das auch sagen wir mal, das betrifft ja auch genug
Leute, von denen man das nicht erwarten würde, ja nicht erwartet hätte ja.
Naja.
Aber es hat sich die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, hat eine Studie in Auftrag gegeben
oder jetzt veröffentlicht, die quasi untersucht,
welche Strategien die liberalen Demokratien entwickeln im Umgang mit erstarkenden
rechtsextremen Parteien.
Und das haben sie sich angeschaut in Finnland, Frankreich, Griechenland,
Italien, Niederlanden, Österreich, Polen, Schweden, Spanien und der Tschechischen Republik.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich nicht getraut, sich das auch in Deutschland anzugucken,
weil sie dann gewusst hätten, egal was wir hier schreiben, kommt wieder irgendeiner
und flippt aus. Und wenn es nur Julian Reichelt ist.
Und jetzt also das ist ein relativ langes Paper ich habe es auch noch nicht
ganz zu Ende gelesen oder also noch nicht ganz gelesen aber ich habe das Ende
gelesen und ich finde das auf jeden Fall mal sehr interessant,
weil das natürlich alles irgendwie so ein Thema ist,
am Ende sagen sie, dass es im Prinzip drei vielversprechende Strategien gibt
und jetzt zitiere ich mal aus dieser Veröffentlichung so ein bisschen das.
Die drei Wege. Sie sagen, die eine ist, die Partei bekämpfen,
Aber die Wählerinnen und Wähler umarmen Spaniens Partido Popular als Vorbild.
Und zwar gibt es in Spanien eine rechtspopulitische Bewegung mit dem Namen VOX.
Und die Partido Popular spricht migrations- und souveränitätsbezogene Themen
glaubwürdig an, nimmt Sorgen und Wünsche von VOX-Sympathisantinnen und Sympathisanten ernst,
ohne sich dabei aber mit der Partei selbst gemein zu machen oder Unterschiede zu verwässern.
Botschaft lautet, wir verstehen eure Sorgen, wir verstehen, was ihr wollt,
aber wir belassen euch nicht den polternden und radikalen Anführern der VOX.
Dann sagen sie, das wäre, oder sie kommen zu dem Ergebnis, dass es mit dieser
Strategie der PP immer wieder gelungen ist, VOX relativ klein zu halten. Okay.
Okay, die haben aber schon auch irgendwie Kooperationen in einzelnen Regionen gehabt.
Und das war aber immer unter der Führung der Partido Popular.
Dadurch hat die VOX an Profil verloren und weiter an Zustimmung verloren.
Zu dem Ergebnis kommen die Autoren.
Okay, also die Wählerinnen und Wähler ernst nehmen, die Partei bekämpfen.
Zweite Strategie, programmatische Lethargie überwinden, Griechenlands Neademokratia als Vorbild.
Neademokratia hat die Themen Migrationssicherheit und Souveränität selbstbewusst
besetzt, ohne in populistische Vereinfachung oder rechtsextreme Fahrwasser zu geraten.
Hat eine klare Linie zu Heleniki, Lisi, Niki und den Spartans gezogen und sie
dadurch klein gehalten,
konnten also mit,
mit programmatischem Anspruch die Themen parteiintern diskutieren,
schwierige Fragen intensiv sich damit auseinandergesetzt und damit Themenführerschaft
behalten und politisch sich abgrenzen können von den Rechten oder von den extremen Rechten.
Also tatsächlich auch mal was tun.
Und dann das dritte Beispiel, Kokomus aus Finnland, die Verlässlichkeit belohnen
und Radikalisierung sanktionieren.
Der Kokomus regiert mit den,
rechtspopulistischen Finnen. Gut, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht,
was das jetzt gerade die Bekämpfungsstrategie ist, aber okay.
Aber unter klaren Bedingungen. Sie sagen Null Toleranz für rassistische oder
demokratiefeindliche Entgleisungen.
Klare Verantwortung für Regierungsarbeit, rote Linie bei Verfassungsfragen.
Tatsächlich würde, sagen sie, die EVP, also diese Kokomus gehört der EVP an,
Europäische Volkspartei ist das dann glaube ich, das ist der Zusammenschluss
der Rechtskonservativen im Europaparlament und sagen, sie sehen das mal als Test an.
Nationale Sammlungspartei heißt es.
Naja, ja.
Ah, okay.
Kann Salinenkukumus. Ich kann auch keinen finnisch, aber so.
Nee, das ist auch nicht einfach.
Nee, in der Tat.
Was ich interessant finde ist, also was heißt das?
Gut, das Letzte ist ja so ein bisschen quasi den politischen,
Kulturwaren. Das Zweite ist, die Themenfelder auch besetzen.
Und das Erste ist, ja, die Partei bekämpfen, aber nicht die Wählerinnen und Wähler.
Alle drei, denke ich, Strategien, wo man hoffen würde, dass vielleicht so ein
Friedrich Merz das auch mal liest,
und vielleicht nochmal sich überlegt und vielleicht nochmal nachschärft bei
seiner angeblichen Strategie, die AfD zu halbieren oder was.
Hat ja gut geklappt. Was ist in NRW jetzt rausgekommen? Weiß nicht.
Vor drei oder vierfach oder was haben die da jetzt? Haben sie auf jeden Fall,
sehr, sehr starke Zuwächse gehabt, die AfD. Auf 14 Prozent. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo sie es sind.
Ich glaube, es war eine Verdopplung, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Tja. Naja. Das klingt alles ganz sinnvoll. Allerdings sind das auch, glaube ich, dann,
Sachen, die immer sehr im Kontext des jeweiligen Landes gesehen werden sollen.
Wobei jetzt diese Studie wohl auch auf andere Länder noch geschaut hat,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Auch Österreich, Polen.
Genau. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum Sie jetzt nur diese drei als Vorbilder bezeichnen.
Die österreichische Lösung war ja auch so funktioniert.
Ja, in Schweden, Schweden-Demokraten ist auch schwierig. Tschechien kann ich
nicht einschätzen gut italien haben wir die meloni,
Das hat auch nicht geklappt.
Die wird sich jetzt entzaubern.
Ja, entzaubern. Auf der anderen Seite zeigt sie ja auch eine interessante Realpolitik.
Mit diesen rechtsextremen Gruppen in Europa ist das halt auch so eine Sache.
Die sind nicht alle irgendwie aus dem selben Holz geschnitzt.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Also Front National kann die AfD nicht leiden. irgendwie Meloni hat einen guten
Stand eigentlich so auf europäischer Ebene und macht ja eigentlich auch eine ganz sinnvolle,
internationale Politik in Bezug auf den Ukraine-Krieg zum Beispiel.
Also es ist alles nach wie vor sehr diffus.
Aber was ja jetzt hier eigentlich diese Studie im Kern sagt ist,
wir, also die Leute, die diese Studie gemacht haben, denken,
es wäre sinnvoll, wenn man halt sich quasi den Themen annimmt,
ohne jetzt irgendwie den Gesang nachzusingen.
Also nicht einfach ein Pfälzerlied singen, wie das jetzt irgendwie aus dem Telefon
kommt, sondern halt einfach ein eigenes Lied,
erfinden und ja, das klingt natürlich immer sehr einfach, aber man muss natürlich
gerade in so einer Partei auch immer auch Wege finden.
Ich meine, wenn jetzt die Grünen angefangen haben, wir müssen jetzt hier mal
auch auf die Bedenken der Migration, also der Bedenkenträger eingehen,
was ja im Prinzip hier steht,
Dann hast du ja natürlich auch sofort die grüne Wählerschaft,
die aufschreit und sagt, wie könnt ihr nur überhaupt das Thema aufgreifen.
Also sehr schwierig sowas auch durchzusetzen.
Nicht unmöglich, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schwierig.
Diese blank liegenden Nerven, das ist wirklich schwierig.
Das Internet ist leider nicht hilfreich dabei.
Das Internet ist absolut nicht hilfreich.
Aber eigentlich ist das ja alles nichts Neues.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt diese Themen auf einmal so aus dem Nichts herauskommen
würden, sondern es ist einfach immer die gleiche Scheiße.
Egal auf welches Jahrzehnt du schaust, geht es den Leuten irgendwie auf einmal
nicht mehr so gut wirtschaftlich.
Dann werden einfach irgendwelche Gruppen gesucht, die an einem schuld sind.
Dass man sich bloß nicht selber ändern muss, sondern das sind immer die anderen schuld.
Und wer dann am lautesten schreit, dass sie ja erkannt haben,
dass die anderen schuld sind, das ist dann irgendwie die Politik du jour,
die versucht sich mit radikalem Marktgeschrei durchzusetzen.
Jetzt haben wir aber das Internet mit den ganzen Gesellschaftsmedien,
die dazu führen, dass die Leute einfach...
Eine Überdosis an Nachrichten haben, permanent natürlich auch diese ganze Propaganda
von links und rechts gefüttert bekommen, wie dieses erwähnte Nios,
wo dann halt einfach alles verdreht wird und,
es auch bei vielen Leuten dazu führt, dass sie einfach dann auch gar keine Meinung mehr haben.
Einfach dieses, ja, das ist ja auch dieses russische Propagandaprinzip.
Flute einfach diesen ganzen,
Informationsbereich mit tausend Aussagen, die sich am besten auch noch alle
widersprechen, damit die Leute einfach die Haltung einnehmen,
ich verstehe nichts mehr,
mich macht das alles wütend, ich weiß zwar nicht, wer an irgendwas schuld ist,
aber ich glaube jetzt auch einfach gar nichts mehr.
Und deswegen ist es ja auch so schwierig, mit einem klaren Kopf und mit einer
klaren Botschaft und einer guten Analyse überhaupt noch durchzukommen.
Weil du bist dann einfach auch nur eine Botschaft von tausenden,
die sich alle angeblich widersprechen und die Leute sind irgendwie nicht in
der Lage und ich kann das auch nachvollziehen, dass es schwierig ist,
da sich zu orientieren, Leute sind einfach nicht mehr in der Lage,
überhaupt noch klare Leute mit klarem Verstand von den Leuten,
die keinen klaren Verstand haben, zu unterscheiden.
Einfach weil zu viel gleichzeitig geschrien wird und das müssten sich einfach
alle mal hinsetzen und wahrscheinlich müsste das Internet ausscheiden für eine
Weile, aber das wird halt nicht mehr passieren.
Und was mir so auffällt, wenn man sich das so alles anschaut und was ja auch
wirklich faszinierend irritierend ist,
wer hat das nochmal gesagt, nur die dümmsten Kälber wählen ihre Schlachter selber,
das war glaube ich Brecht, oder?
Ich bitte das mit meiner Bildungsfernsehabilitation zu entschuldigen,
wenn ich das jetzt nicht richtig.
Weil man sich ja die Trump-Politik anschaut und denkt, das was der da macht,
also die Leute, die ihn wählen, auf jeden Fall agiert er zu deren Nachteil.
Also diese bildungsferne, ökonomisch schwache,
Flyover-Country-Prekariat-Leute, Rednecks irgendwie, die sagen,
das ist das Geilste jetzt hier, Donald Trump.
Also die profitieren auf jeden Fall nicht von seiner Politik.
Das ist ja schon wirklich faszinierend, wie du das hinkriegst.
Und das funktioniert ja sehr offensichtlich deshalb, weil Politik mit den Emotionen
gemacht wird und nicht mit den tatsächlich rationalen Inhalten.
Und das ist halt wirklich, wirklich schlimm.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich schlimm, wenn es soweit ist, weil wir das mit dieser
Politik ja machen, um unsere störenden, wilden Emotionen da rauszuhalten.
Wir bauen ja diesen ganzen Kram, Parlament, Wahl,
Richter, drei Gewalten geteilt, um irgendwo sicherzustellen,
dass wir möglichst eine Balance haben, wo irgendwo nochmal eine erwachsene Person sitzt,
die ein Verantwortungsbewusstsein hat und versucht grob das Richtige zu tun.
Oder auch mit Sensibilität dieser Große der Herausforderungen zu begegnen.
Und wenn du das aber einfach rumtrittst und hetzt die Leute in jede Richtung.
Dann sind die halt machtlos. Und dann ist die gesamte Gesellschaft machtlos
und lässt sich irgendwie in den Irrsinn treiben, in den Hass gegeneinander,
quasi in Politik, die einem selber halt hardcore schadet und deswegen,
ja, wir müssen als Menschen die ganze Zeit unsere Emotionen im Griff halten,
das ist die Herausforderung,
insbesondere im politischen meine Güte, also was habe ich manchmal für Emotionen,
die ich im Griff halten muss so, aber da kann man wunderschöne Algorithmen machen.
Bevor die Leute schreiben jetzt schon in die Kommentare rein.
Stopp halt. Also es ist offenbar nicht von Brecht.
Sondern ich hab mal im Internet recherchiert. Für euch.
Und keine Ahnung, ob ich jetzt wieder auf der falschen Formation gelandet bin.
Aber es ist wohl eine Zuschreibung. Es gibt allerdings einen von Bertolt Brecht einen Kälbermarsch,
wo er irgendwie eine Parodie des Horst-Wessel-Liedes macht und da schreibt er,
hinter der Trommel her trotten die Kälber, das Feld für die Trommel liefern sie selber.
Der Schlechter ruft, die Augen fest geschlossen, das Kalb marschiert in ruhigen Fristen tritt.
Die Kälber, deren Blut im Schlachthaus schon geflossen, marschieren im Geist in seinen Reihen mit.
Da mag es seinen Ursprung haben, dass dieser Satz ihm zugeschrieben wird.
Ansonsten sei das wohl irgendwie auf dem Schweizer Stimmzettel das erste Mal.
Ja Tim, du musst ein anderes Internet als ich.
Weil Welches?
Moment.
Welches Internet hast du denn?
Ich hab Telekom Internet.
Achso. Bist du schon drin oder was?
Interessant, tatsächlich also ich habe jetzt mehrere Quellen gefunden die das
tatsächlich direkt Berthold Brecht zuschreiben und dann ein,
das ist ihm fälschlich zu meine Güte also jetzt Schweigen der Kälber okay Schweigen der Kälber.
Ich würde sagen, wir eröffnen jetzt einfach die Kommentarsaison.
Ihr werdet uns schon erzählen, was stimmt und was nicht stimmt,
weil was wissen wir schon?
Wir haben ja keine Ahnung. Wir reden ja auch nur so daher.
So, dann genau, also wie kommt das, dass Menschen,
irgendwie nur noch emotional sind? Ja, ich denke, da hat diese.
Veröffentlichung der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung durchaus einen Punkt,
weil sie auch weil sie sicherlich nicht unbedingt das Gefühl haben,
dass sie rational noch irgendwie von irgendjemandem dass sie überhaupt noch jemand interessiert.
Oder dass sie einfach sagen, ich will das jetzt auch einfach brennen sehen,
ich habe auch keinen Bock mehr.
Es gibt ja auch genug Leute, die sich jetzt wirklich von der Politik abwenden
und sagen, nee, komm, ich habe einfach keine Lust, mich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Und das ist sicherlich auch für die seelische Gesundheit gar nicht so verkehrt.
Das ist aber halt ein Problem.
Wir haben mit diesem Internet,
uns etwas geschaffen, was immer und immer schneller und immer und immer weniger
und immer und immer emotionaler für uns ist.
Also, wenn ich mir das jetzt so über die Jahre anschaue, ja gut,
dann gab es irgendwie, in irgendwelchen Foren haben die Leute sich dann da bekämpft,
okay, das waren aber das, immerhin haben die sich noch miteinander unterhalten.
Dann kam Mit Mailinglisten ging es los Ja gut.
Das war schon ein Fehler Dann kamen die sozialen Netzwerke die ersten,
MySpace, Facebook und so vor 15, 20 Jahren die waren ja quasi noch das war ja
noch halbwegs also im Vergleich zu heute war das ja,
geradezu,
langweilig, dass da Leute, was
da Leute an Texte schreiben konnten und für Diskussionen geführt haben.
Heute wirst du irgendwie mit Reels von Instagram und YouTube und TikTok vollgeballert
und es kommt selten vor, dass du überhaupt irgendwas zu Ende guckst.
Also das, was irgendwie früher schon das Zappen war, was aus irgendwie wie Langeweile
vorm Fernseher passiert ist, weil man irgendwie ja seine 180 Fernsehkanäle nutzen musste,
für die man da bezahlt hat und dachte, man hätte jetzt irgendwie Vielfalt.
Das sind halt jetzt diese sogenannten sozialen Medien, in denen alle halt so
laut umeinander schreien müssen.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, von wem dieser Vergleich stammt.
Ich glaube, das hatte Frank Rieger mal gesagt.
Ich glaube sogar bei uns in der Sendung. So,
In diesen sozialen Medien, du versuchst halt eigentlich ein Plenum zu machen,
aber du machst es halt im Fußballstadion und jeder hat eine Trommel und die
Leute schreien einfach nur noch um sich.
Und dann gibt es einen Algorithmus, der guckt, naja, was hat denn die höchste
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand bei uns bleibt?
Was hat die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Leute hier engagiert bleiben?
Und diesem Algorithmus optimierend haben sich YouTube entwickelt,
hat sich Facebook entwickelt, hat sich Twitter entwickelt.
Gut, die haben dann irgendwann nochmal gesagt, na, und jetzt stellen wir den
mal so um, dass da auch ein anderer politischer Tenor herrscht.
Und wir haben uns viele Jahre schon darüber Gedanken gemacht,
was damit natürlich auch für Manipulationspotenzial in einer Gesellschaft vorherrscht,
weil du eben bestimmte Stimmen lauter und präsenter erscheinen lassen kannst,
als sie es vielleicht sind.
Und das ist ja das, was beispielsweise auf so etwas wie Twitter passiert.
Und die Änderungen, die da stattgefunden haben, ich glaube, da könnte man mal
noch die alten Folgen Logbuch Netzpolitik sehen. Das habe ich absolut nicht mitgerechnet.
Absolut unterschätzt, was da beispielsweise, also vor allem wie schnell das gehen würde.
Und wenn sich diese Welt um dich herum so ändert, übrigens in dem Zusammenhang ganz interessant.
Und du findest üblicherweise,
wenn es öffentliche Ermordungen gibt oder Amokläufe oder so und Leute davon Videos machen,
beispielsweise Christchurch, das war ja dieses Christchurch-Ding,
Das war ja ein Amokläufer, Attentäter, wie auch immer.
Mörder, Massenmörder, was auch immer der korrekte Begriff ist,
der das live gestreamt hat.
Und seitdem haben die sozialen Netzwerke sich sehr dafür optimiert,
dass wenn Inhalte gemeldet werden, dass sie auch verschwinden.
Und dieses Video von Christchurch zu finden, wenn du das hättest sehen wollen,
hättest du dir sehr viel Mühe geben müssen, weil das halt weg war,
ja, natürlich konntest du das irgendwo,
was weiß ich in irgendeinem Torrent, in irgendeinem, weiß der Geier,
in irgendeinem komischen Forum, da konntest du das schon finden,
aber du musstest das aktiv suchen.
Die Ermordung von Charlie Kirk, die musst du nicht aktiv suchen,
die fliegt dir die ganze Zeit auf Twitter um die Ohren. Und das ist...
Beobachte ich auch erstaunt, dass das jetzt quasi, dass du diese,
und das ist ein grausames Video,
dass du jetzt wirklich, wie gesagt, da scrollst du einmal runter,
also du brauchst ja nicht mehr zu scrollen, das ist ja sofort da.
Und das, glaube ich, wundert mich auf jeden Fall, weil das lange Zeit nicht so war.
Und das ist natürlich schon auch eine etwas interessante Erfahrung,
dass das jetzt ausgerechnet bei diesem Mord die ganze Zeit passiert.
Und die Folgen auf die Menschen, die das sehen, sind ja auch klar.
Ich meine, wenn du so etwas siehst und sagst, dass es so eine grausame Tat findet hier statt.
Vor meiner Tür mit jemandem, der die Dinge sagt, die ich spüre.
Nämlich, dass es nur ein Geschlecht gibt oder zwei.
Oder irgendein Quatsch, der jetzt in der Bibel steht oder wo auch immer.
Dann macht das was mit Menschen. Und da kannst du die sehr viel einfacher mit
steuern, als wenn du sagst, ich gebe euch mal ein Argument dafür,
dass es nur zwei Geschlechter geben soll. oder dass das jetzt ein Problem ist,
wenn es drei oder vier gibt.
Da habe ich bisher noch nicht festgestellt, dass das für irgendjemanden...
Also es gibt offensichtlich für viele Leute, ist das ein Problem,
aber das ist kein rational formulierbares.
Das ist offen, also das ist nur ein emotional formulierbares und genau deswegen
wird es halt emotional gehetzt.
Und das ist halt erst möglich geworden, dadurch, dass du zentrale soziale Netzwerke,
sogenannte Netzwerke, hast.
Und dann kam TikTok, weil die sozialen Netzwerke waren ja alle von den USA.
Das war irgendwie Twitter, Facebook.
Hier in Deutschland gab es mal irgendwie kurz StudiVZ oder so.
Aber die großen, einflussreichen sozialen Netzwerke, die sind in Amerika.
Und dann kam TikTok auf einmal aus dem Nichts.
Und die USA haben gesagt, Moment mal, da könnten ja jetzt die Daten von Millionen
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikanern in die Hände Pekings gelangen.
Und außerdem kann man mit dem Algorithmus von TikTok ja Einfluss auf die öffentliche Meinung nehmen.
Die wissen halt genau, was los ist. Die sagen halt zu denen,
Moment mal, das geht nicht, dass ihr sowas habt.
Das haben wir hier nicht so gerne. Das machen wir.
Und das wird ja auch seit vielen Jahren diskutiert. Dann haben sie irgendwie
TikTok-Verbot. Dann wollten sie TikTok zwingen zum Verkauf.
Dann hat ByteDance, die Firma, der TikTok gehört hat, sich quasi dagegen gewehrt,
dass sie gezwungen werden zu verkaufen. Dann hat Trump immer irgendwelche Gesetze angekündigt.
Und dann hat er jetzt den TikTok-Taco gemacht. Kennst du den TikTok-Taco?
Trump always chickens out.
Genau. Dann hat er gesagt, wir haben einen Deal, super. Ich habe das auch gelöst.
Und jetzt ist er weitergegangen. Jetzt sitzen da irgendwelche Leute und rätseln.
Was ist denn jetzt dieser Deal? Naja,
offenbar wird es jetzt ein US-TikTok geben, das wird ein Konsortium amerikanischer Investoren,
denen rund 80% davon gehören. 20% gehören dann ByteDance.
Im Aufsichtsrat werden auch Amerikaner die Mehrheit stellen.
Ein Sitz direkt von der US-Regierung, die kommt in den Aufsichtsrat von TikTok.
Da müssen sie sicherstellen, dass sie Einblick und Einfluss auf die Geschäfte haben.
Und die Daten.
Die Daten, die kommen halt irgendwie in Oracle-Datenbanken, ein schöner US-Unternehmen,
damit die die Kohle machen.
Aber der Algorithmus, genau das Manipulationsding, das Manipulationsgeheimnis,
das bleibt bei ByteDance.
Und damit wird es quasi, lizenzieren die USA jetzt einen Algorithmus von China in...
Also schon lustig, wie geil man so einen Trump auch verarschen kann.
Der ist jetzt so, Details sind noch nicht, der hat jetzt gesagt,
wir haben einen Deal, zack, nächstes.
Jetzt wird, was weiß ich, was er da jetzt als nächstes löst.
Und dann hinterlässt er ja alle mit irgendwie so, und hat das Problem auch nicht
gelöst, was die USA da haben.
Aber jetzt haben wir einen TikTok-Taco. super.
Also es ist halt, es ist wirklich halt gefährlich, wenn du da,
also diese Werkzeuge und ich glaube, also habe ich ja hier schon oder die Ansicht
vertrete ich schon sehr lange.
Es war bis vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, war das immer noch so ein bisschen so.
Es blieb halt eine theoretische oder eine etwas dumpfe Bedrohung.
Es ist nicht erst jetzt, dass das ein paar Milliardäre sind,
die die Meinungsmacht damit lenken, mit ihren sozialen Netzwerken.
Aber solange da irgendwie eine Regierung hinter saß, die immer noch so ganz
grob halbwegs irgendwo sane war,
War das Risiko eher so nochmal so, die Bedrohung ist da, es macht aber noch
keiner Gebrauch von ihr.
Und jetzt kannst du dir das halt in Sekunden schneller anschauen.
Also auch wenn jetzt Trump von dem Deal redet, unterschrieben ist ja jetzt erstmal
noch gar nichts und China ist da auch noch zurückhaltend.
Nee, nee, klar, aber das ist ja, war doch, hier, der Frieden zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine ist auch noch nicht unterschrieben.
Kein Wunder.
Wieso hat der doch geklärt?
Wir haben ja auch alle anderen Sachen nicht, die angeblich irgendwie schon beschlossen sind.
Aber Technologie, also diese Technologien, die Leute bauen, soziale Netzwerke
und natürlich auch künstliche Intelligenz.
Natürlich wird die genutzt, im Sinne der eigenen politischen Ziele.
Und so gibt es jetzt eine wunderschöne Untersuchung von einem US-Sicherheitsunternehmen.
Ich schaue gerade nicht, dass ich jetzt... Ja, Crowdstrike.
Bevor ich jetzt... Genau, Crowdstrike haben eine Forschung gemacht mit DeepSeq
und haben Prompts gegeben,
in der Regel um Hilfe gebeten, ein Programm zu schreiben.
Und dann haben sie das Einzige, was anders war, in der Äußerung war,
wo der Code und zu welchem Zweck dieser Code angewendet werden würde.
Und wenn du DeepSeek sagst, ich will was bauen, was ein Industrial Control System,
also irgendwie so eine Industrie 4.0 OT Geschichte betreibt,
dann haben 22,8 Prozent der Antworten Schwachstellen beinhaltet.
Wenn du dann aber sagtest, dass diese,
dass du irgendwie der islamische Staat bist, und das brauchst,
dann waren 42% der Antworten unsicher.
Das Gleiche, wenn du irgendwie Tibet, Taiwan oder Falun Gong Assoziationen gegeben
hast, haben die dir auch schlechteren Code gegeben.
Geil.
Teilweise hat es auch gesagt, also sind 60% der Fälle gesagt,
sie würden gar nicht helfen, zum Beispiel beim islamischen Staat und bei Falun Gong.
Aber dass die, der Code, den es dir liefert, schlechter ist. Ja, klar.
Und nochmal, also diese Dinger werden halt bald das Fenster zum Internet sein.
Das ist bald das Fenster zur Welt.
Das ist dein Co-Pilot jeden Tag.
Und der wird halt dann auch, genauso wie das soziale Netzwerk,
in das du reinschaust, von den politischen und ökonomischen Interessen der Betreiberinnen geleitet.
Ja, das ist natürlich wirklich ich jetzt geil, in die Coding-Generators dann
Bewusst-Sicherheitslücken reinzubauen, wenn du das Gefühl hast,
jetzt benutzt du das jemanden, den du gerne hacken möchtest.
Das ist natürlich irgendwie echt speziell.
Ja, und das, also das,
Ist auch sehr naheliegend, ne?
Die wollen mir doch nur meine Coding-Tools wegnehmen.
Kannst du deine komische Vibe-Coder, Tim, hat die Idee?
Der macht den nächsten chinesischen Staatstrojaner. Also deinen Code lass ich bei mir nicht laufen.
Hat sich ausgeweibt.
Hat sich ausgeweibt, ja.
Viperware hast du jetzt.
Viperware.
So, der, ähm Aber zum Glück wissen wir ja, dass diese sozialen Netzwerke,
die werden ja kontrolliert.
Du meinst ja keinem, was passieren.
Nein, nein, nein, die Europäische Union guckt da natürlich drauf.
Ja. Nicht nur die Europäische Union, vor allem auch die europäischen Mitgliedstaaten
schauen da ganz besonders drauf.
Irland vor allem.
Genau, da ist ja Facebook ansässig,
weil da der Datenschutz irgendwie Standortvorteil für Facebook bietet.
Ja, nicht nur für Facebook, sondern auch für Google und Apple und irgendwie
alle Big Tech Companies und TikTok, ja, alle sind irgendwie in Irland,
registriert, weil dann gilt halt dann auch erstmal, dass die Datenschutzbehörde
Irlands und naja, wir haben das ja hier.
Wir haben ja schon sehr oft von Herrn Schrems berichtet,
Neub, die sich dieses Themas ja intensiver angenommen haben und generell lässt
sich glaube ich feststellen, dass Irland es jetzt mit der Verfolgung von diesen
ganzen Datenschutzgesetzen nicht so ernst nimmt.
Was natürlich damit zu tun hat, dass sie auch erheblich davon profitieren,
dass all diese Unternehmen sich in Irland niederlassen.
Irland hat ja insgesamt, seitdem es in der Europäischen Union untergekommen
ist, dann einen ziemlichen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung erlebt und das hat eben
auch sehr viel damit zu tun, mit diesen Tech-Unternehmen.
Und jetzt diese Irish Data Protection Commission, die PC, die also immer wieder
umstritten war, die erhält jetzt einen neuen Commissioner,
derer gibt es drei, also es gibt drei Leiter sozusagen und neu dabei ist eine Niam Sweeney. Ab dem 13.
Oktober wird sie da zustoßen und das ist insofern ganz interessant,
als Niam Sweeney sechs Jahre ihres Lebens damit verbracht hat,
für Meta zu arbeiten und zwar seitens.
Ein paar Jahre für Facebook und ein paar Jahre für WhatsApp und in welchem Bereich?
Im Bereich Public Policy.
Als Lobbyistin.
Genau. Mit anderen Worten, die hat die andere Seite bespielt und jetzt wechselt
sie die Seite und ist von der irischen Regierung in diese,
in diese Kommission gewählt worden oder bestimmt worden.
Ich glaube, es wird nicht gewählt. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es abläuft,
aber viel war die Regierung da die Möglichkeit, das zu besetzen und ja,
das wird ganz interessant.
Ja, bei Neub ist man nicht ganz so begeistert davon.
Könnte man sagen.
Ja, aber weißt du, das wäre ja so, muss man auch wirklich sagen,
das wäre ja, als würdest du irgendwie
so eine Energielobbyistin zur Wiedscherzministerin machen oder sowas.
Also das ist ja schon wirklich auch relativ hart. Also stell dir mal vor,
dann wird es irgendwie so eine...
So, dann gibt es eine kleinere Meldung aus dem Kontext der Biometrie-Erkennungssoftwares.
Und zwar hat das BKA einen Produkttest gemacht.
Und zwar, das haben wir auch, glaube ich, damals berichtet, 2024.
Und die haben sich quasi Gesichtserkennungssoftwares angeschaut.
2018 haben sie diesen Produkttest gemacht und haben 2024 wurde darüber berichtet.
Und jetzt brauchten sie natürlich Gesichter für ihre Gesichtserkennungsdatenbank-Tests.
Und da haben sie gesagt, haben wir doch.
Nennt sich hier Inpol-Set.
Inpol. Da steht für Informationssystem der Polizei in Pol.
Und in Pol Z ist die zentrale Variante davon, wo dann quasi alle Teile zusammengehen.
Und da haben sie natürlich Bilder drin. Und dann haben sie gesagt,
alles klar, dann nehmen wir von denen halt die Bilder und haben dann damit diesen
KI-Trainings-Test gemacht. Ja.
Und dann gibt es, also diese Leute, das waren also die drei Millionen Personen
waren das, die da betroffen waren.
Und die haben natürlich nicht bei ihrer erkennungsdienstlichen Behandlung durch
das BKA gesagt, ja, nee, klar, du kannst eine KI trainieren.
Das hat die BKA ungefähr so wie LinkedIn dann gemacht. Die haben einfach die
Option nachher hinzugefügt und das Häkchen schon mal für dich automatisch angemacht.
Und ja, sagen wir, es war erforderlich, weil die Gesichtserkennung hat ja eine
hohe Bedeutung für die Strafverfolgung.
Und deswegen mussten wir das machen.
Weil wir mussten das Gesichtserkennungssystem im BKA ertüchtigen.
Und haben halt, na ja.
Sogar 5 Millionen, Drei bis fünf Millionen Inpol-Z-Bilder genommen,
dann dem Fraunhofer-Institut für grafische Datenverarbeitung gegeben und dann
hat das Fraunhofer-Institut eben unterschiedliche Gesichtserkennungssoftwares
unterschiedlicher Hersteller evaluiert.
So eine der Personen, die in dieser Datenbank drin war,
klagt jetzt, das ist Yannick Besendorf, der klagt mit Unterstützung des Chaos
Computer Clubs die Sache jetzt durch, um sich feststellen zu lassen,
dass diese Verwendung seines Gesichtsbildes eben, da ja keiner Rechtsgrundlage
hatte, mit anderen Worten rechtswidrig war.
Ja, ich will also nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, weil ich mit den Jahren,
glaube ich, durcheinander gekommen bin.
Also 2018 ist der Yannick in diese Datenbank gekommen, 2019 wurden diese Bilder
dann vom BKA an Fraunhofer gegeben.
Und darüber wurde 2024, wenn ich das richtig sehe, zum ersten Mal wahrscheinlich
zumindest bei uns berichtet.
Also zum ersten Mal haben wir, nein, haben wir erstmalig davon berichtet.
Und den Abschlussbericht gibt es natürlich bei Frag den Staat.
Also, ja, Ist halt lustig, wie so Polizei mit ihren Daten, die gehen da auch
nicht besser mit um als irgendwie so ein Facebook oder so ein TikTok oder so.
Zum Schluss aber noch ein bisschen IT-Pan. Das müssen wir kurz erwähnen.
Ist ja manchen aufgefallen, die zum Beispiel in Berlin einen Flug nehmen wollten vor ein paar Tagen.
Ging nicht so gut, weil das Check-in-System ausgefallen ist.
Das Check-in-System ist deshalb ausgefallen, weil das Check-in-System und Boarding
eine Dienstleistung ist, die von einem externen Anbieter bereitgestellt wird
für den Berliner Flughafen.
Ist auch nicht der Einzige, der das tut, sondern auch in Münster,
Osnabrück, Brüssel und noch ein paar andere,
wird diese Dienstleistung in Anspruch genommen von der Firma Collins Aerospace,
die eigentlich mehr so im Herstellersegment ist, die eine Tochter ist von ATX,
das war vormals Raytheon, also eine US-amerikanische Militärproduktionsfirma.
Und die haben offensichtlich aber auch IT-Dienstleistungen, weil macht man heutzutage
so und haben halt so Check-in und Boarding-Systeme bereitgestellt.
Aber die wurden jetzt irgendwie weggecybert und ja, da gab es dann wohl,
war das eine Ransomware-Attacke?
Ja.
Genau, also hier Stand and Deliver, wir haben alle eure Daten verkryptifiziert, gibt uns Geld.
Ja, und dann musste halt mal jeder Koffer von Hand beschriftet werden,
damit das Flugzeug dann auch losfliegen konnte. Nicht so gut gelaufen.
Also ein Freund schrieb mir von heute Morgen vom Flughafen, dass da Check-in
manuell mit einem Blatt Papier.
Ja, ist doof, wenn so ein Dienst ausfällt.
Ja, kann man...
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ich bin überrascht, dass sie so einen externen Dienstleister haben.
Würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so erforderlich und klug ist.
Ähm,
Also tatsächlich ist das ein bisschen, also weil diese ganze Flug-IT über so
viele Jahre gewachsen ist,
ist das eigentlich alles voll mit irgendwelchen Dienstleistern.
Also beispielsweise dieses ganze System mit den Amadeus-Codes,
den sechs Zeichen-Codes, die so immer für die Tickets dann gelten.
Und der Hintergrund davon ist, dass es sind halt weltumspannende,
naja, woanders würde man das einen Standard nennen, aber in diesem Fall ist es eben ein Service,
der quasi eine Standardkonzeption dafür hat, dass du mit deinem Ticket eben
auch an dem Flughafen Einlass bekommst, an den Boarding Gates.
Und diese Unternehmen, die das halt weltweit anbieten als Service.
Die lassen sich das natürlich ganz gut kosten. und deswegen hast du da so einen
großen Zoo an letztendlich Dingen,
die so eine Airline dann konsumiert von dem Amadeus-hasse-nicht-gesehen-System,
das dann wiederum an den Flughäfen diese Einlassdinger, die Boarding-Gates und so weiter dann da macht.
Und das ist ja auch nicht ganz so einfach, weil dann eben vor dem Security-Check
ja einmal kontrolliert wird, ob du überhaupt ein Ticket hast,
dann wird kontrolliert, ob du da reingehst und das ist halt vereinheitlicht und deswegen,
weil damit die ganzen Airlines sich nicht interoperabel sein müssen oder nicht
direkt mit dem Flughafen interfacen müssen, sind da überall irgendwelche Dienstleister drin.
Hätte natürlich erwartet, dass sie vielleicht Vorkehrungen getroffen haben,
dass sie nicht von der Ransomware runtergerafft werden und dann irgendwie,
alles wieder mit Papier gemacht werden muss. Aber ja, sieht ganz,
ist immer wieder unterhaltsam, wenn mal sowas ausfällt, was man für,
für selbstverständlich hält. Zum Beispiel so eine Wahl.
Ja, also Münster ist doppelt betroffen, nicht nur der Flughafen.
Wobei die sich wohl relativ schnell wieder gerade gerückt haben,
habe ich gelesen, aber weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Aber bei der Wahl gab es dann wieder ein bisschen Vibration.
Ja, und zwar ist es wieder die Software Vote Manager,
die Thorsten und ich ja beim 38C3 uns nochmal angeschaut hatten,
nachdem wir vor vielen Jahren ja schon mal mit Martin uns eine Wahlsoftware angeschaut hatten.
Und ja, es gab Überlastungen und sehr viele Kommunen konnten teilweise entweder
Ergebnisse nicht anzeigen lassen oder eben Ergebnisse nicht übermitteln.
In Bocholt setzten sich die Mitarbeiter des Wahlbüros ins Auto und brachten
die Ergebnisse persönlich nach Borken.
Und in drei Dutzend Kommunen in den Kreisen Kleve, Wesel und Viersen,
die hatten halt Probleme mit der Darstellung,
weil das zuständige Kommunale Rechenzentrum in Kamp-Lindfort irgendwie Teile
der Daten nur übertragen konnte und was auch immer.
Es war wieder eine absolute Shitshow, aber beim Test hat es noch alles funktioniert.
Eben wollten wir noch das Internet abschalten, weil die Leute sich irgendwie,
durchs Internet einfach wirr werden und jetzt ist es auch wieder nicht recht,
wenn sie jetzt besuchen kommen, das Auto setzen, hinfahren, Hallo sagen, Hand geben.
Naja, im Niederrhein ist ein Rechenzentrum,
technischer Fehler im Rechenzentrum.
Was für technischer Fehler passiert dir in deinem Rechenzentrum am Wahlsonntag,
wenn du einmal anmachen musst?
Und Greven hat dann die Kommunen abtelefoniert.
Diese Lösung haben wir ja dann auch schon in unserem Vortrag nochmal gezeigt.
Ja, das ist die beste Software, die wir haben. Es gibt halt auch nur noch eine.
So, Schluss jetzt hier. Das war's mit der Sendung.
Und mir fällt nicht mehr viel ein, was wir am Ende noch Blödes dazu kommentieren können.
Nö, das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Ja, dir auch nicht, willst du sagen?
Nö, ja.
Kannst du auch noch mal das Pfälzerlied singen oder so?
Pizzalied?
Das Pfälzerlied kannst du singen.
Das kannst du...
Ich hab keinen Cut, du musst das singen.
Okay, gut.
Eigentlich ja, meine Güte, kannst du mal ein Pfälzerlied singen.
Also, ein bisschen Spaß muss sein. Ja, ein bisschen Spaß muss sein.
In diesem Sinne, wünschen wir euch eine angenehme Woche. Bis bald.
Geh mal in die frische Luft. Ciao, ciao.